schauen auf die Explosionen auf der
krimbrücke vom Wochenende und jetzt
wollen Putins Leute angeblich wissen wer
das getan hat Russland hat nach eigenen
Aussagen attrakt
mutmaßliche Täter für diese Explosionen
auf der krimbrücke festgenommen ja und
als Rache eben für diese Explosionen da
hat es Putin jetzt mit seinen Truppen
umso mehr auf die Infrastruktur der
Ukraine abgesehen vor allem eben auf die
Stromversorgung der Plan die Ukraine im
Winter einfach einfrieren
lange Zeit sah so aus als würde sich das
Blatt im Ukraine Konflikt zugunsten der
Ukraine wenden immer wieder gab es in
den vergangenen Wochen Nachrichten über
Rückeroberungen und militärische Erfolge
der ukrainischen Truppen
doch der Kreml Diktator Putin schmiedet
neue Pläne um die Ukraine in die Knie zu
zwingen
Auslöser für die neueste
angriffsoffensive der Russen der
vermeintliche sabotage-aktie
jetzt greift Moskau gezielt die
kritische Infrastruktur des Landes an
und will die noch verbliebene
Energieversorgung sowie die
Heizkraftwerke in der Ukraine zerstören
das Ausmaß dieses Vorgehens bekommt die
Bevölkerung bereits zu spüren zum
Beispiel in Lemberg hier kam es durch
die Raketenangriffe zum strohmangel auch
die Wärmekraftwerke mussten abgestellt
werden auch in krativ wurde ein
Kraftwerk getroffen mehrere Stadtteile
haben noch immer keinen Strom und kein
warmes Wasser
und genau das ist es was putin will
einen eiskalten Winter für die Ukraine
um die Moral der Soldaten zu schwächen
um die Bevölkerung zu tyrannisieren um
den Krieg für sich zu gewinnen
Putins Rechnung je mehr die Bevölkerung
unter der Kälte leidet je mehr die
Grundversorgung gefährdet ist desto eher
könnte der Durchhaltewille gebrochen
werden doch auch russische Soldaten
müssen den harten Winter überstehen
Schnee und Kälte werden das Schlachtfeld
für die beiden Seiten unwegsam machen
nicht nur der ukrainischen Bevölkerung
steht ein harter Winter bevor auch die
als modernen propagierte russische Armee
wird mit Putins neuester Strategie zu
kämpfen haben
aber diese Strategie waren wir sprechen
mit Paul ronsheimer zugeschaltet aus der
Ukraine aus Kiew Paul also
offensichtlich will Putin jetzt die
Ukraine einfrieren in ein eiskalten
Winter bescheren wie realistisch ist
denn dieser Plan
das ist schon etwas vor dem die
offiziellen hier sorgen haben also der
Kirmes Bürgermeister z.B Vitali
Klitschko warnt davor und hat die
Bevölkerung auch schon darauf
eingestimmt viele bereiten sich hier vor
mit Feuerholz und holen sich Wärme
Strahler in die Wohnung man muss
natürlich wissen dass auch die
wirtschaftliche Lage hier ziemlich
katastrophal ist also vor allem die
einkommensschwächeren sind betroffen in
den Regionen rund um Kia was geht längst
nicht nur um die Hauptstadt sondern um
das gesamte Land das ist davon
auszugehen dass bei Temperaturen von
dann im Winter bis zu -20 - 30 Grad das
kann Dir passieren in der Ukraine ist
Kältetote geben könnte dass ja Menschen
erfrieren können durch immer neue
Angriffe eben auf die Infrastruktur in
der Ukraine Paul du bist weiterhin
mittendrin in diesem Krieg nach bald
acht Monaten dort im Ukraine Krieg und
du bringst uns ein besonders traurige
Familiengeschichte in diesen Tagen mit
die Geschichte von Oxana von ox und von
ihrem fünf Jahre alten Sohn Krischer
Oxana Ärztin 36 Jahre alt sie war auf
dem Weg ins Krankenhaus am Anfang dieser
Woche und ihr Sohn Krischer der
fünfjährige er ist der Einzige der jetzt
aus dieser kleinen Familie noch lebt er
wird zum vollweisen wieso pauli
hier an dieser Kreuzung an der ich stehe
Kai also mitten im Berufsverkehr ich
zeig mal rüber hier ist vorgestern eine
Rakete explodiert und Oxana sie war mit
ihrem Auto auf dem Weg hatte ihren Sohn
grischer abgegeben in einem in einer
Kita dort ist er dann in den
Bombenkeller gegangen es gab schon
Beschuss und sie wollte schnell ins
Krankenhaus sie ist krebsärztin dort sie
hat Menschen vor allem Kindern dort das
Leben gerettet und auf dem Weg wo die
ihr Auto dort getroffen das ist jetzt
bereits zubetoniert wieder nach 48
Stunden und ihr Vater kam dann hierher
Gregory weil er seine Tochter nicht
erreicht hat am Telefon weil er
verzweifelt versucht hat sie zu
erreichen und ihm wurde dann gesagt von
der Polizei das seine Tochter nicht mehr
lebt dass das Auto getroffen wurde der
Junge ist jetzt voll Weise weil auf der
Vater vor einem Jahr gestorben ist es
zeigt die ganze Dramatik und Grausamkeit
Jesus Krieges Kai Zivilisten auf dem Weg
zur Arbeit von einer russischen Rakete
getroffen ein kleiner fünfjähriger Junge
der jetzt keine Mutter mehr hat und der
auch schon keinen Vater mehr hat der
junge selbst weiß noch nicht dass seine
Mutter tot ist so hat uns der Opa
erzählt der sich jetzt künftig um ihn
kümmern will denn Eltern hat er nicht
mehr Herrn Paul du sagst du hast eben
mit diesem Großvater gesprochen wir
wollen uns gemeinsam noch mal dieses
wirklich tragische Schicksal dieser
Familie anschauen
Oxana Leon tierva 36 Ärztin Mutter eines
fünfjährigen Sohnes die Mutter von
Grischa sie stirbt in Putins Bombenhagel
beim groß angelegten Raketenangriff auf
ukrainische Städte bei den Luftschlägen
die auch Kiew treffen Putins Vergeltung
für die Bombenexplosion auf der
krimbrücke
Oxana Leonie am Morgen bringt sie den
Kleinen grischer zu ihrem Vater seinem
Opa denn nach der Ankündigung möglicher
Bombenanschläge bleibt krischers
Kindergarten zu er sieht seine Mutter an
diesem Morgen das letzte Mal denn nur
Minuten später auf dem Weg zu ihrer
Arbeit ins nationale Kinderkrankenhaus
mitten in der Rush Hour schlagen mehrere
Raketen in Kiew ein Treffen das Zentrum
der Stadt treffen ihr Auto töten Oxana
Leon tierba ihr Vater hört von den
Explosionen sieht die Bilder des
Angriffs er greift sofort zum Hörer
[Musik]
als ich in einem der Messenger das Video
der Explosion sah dass jemand aus dem
Auto heraus gefilmt und veröffentlicht
hatte rief ich sie an ich begann sie
anzurufen niemand antwortete ich rief
bei ihrer Arbeit an und ihre Chefin
sagte mir dass sie noch nicht angekommen
war ich verstand dass sie nicht bei der
Arbeit war also machte ich mir Sorgen
und kam hierher alles war eingezäunt und
es gab kein Feuer mehr ich fragte ein
Polizisten ob es ein Auto wie das meiner
Tochter gäbe sie fragten nach dem
Kennzeichen und sagten dass das Auto da
sei und eine Leiche auf dem Vordersitz
liege sie zeigten mir das Nummernschild
dass sie auf der Straße gefunden hatten
der kleine fünfjährige Grischa ist jetzt
voll Weise auch sein Vater oxanas Mann
Tod er stirbt ganz plötzlich Anfang des
Jahres grischer weiß noch nicht dass
seine Mutter nie wiederkommen wird
wir haben es Krischer noch nicht erzählt
Oxana ist oft Überstunden bei der Arbeit
geblieben bis jetzt denkt er dass seine
Mutter arbeitet und dass sie hart
arbeitet heute oder morgen werden wir
ihm diese Informationen mitteilen damit
es nicht zu spät ist
der fünfjährige Grischa er soll nun bei
seinem Opa aufwachsen
was für ein Schicksal dass du uns hier
erzählst Paul mitten aus diesem Ukraine
Krieg an dem Tag an dem wir hören aus
Moskau das angeblich acht Tatverdächtige
gefunden worden festgenommen worden die
ja verantwortlich sein sollen für diesen
Angriff auf die krimbrücke an dem Tag an
dem wir gerade hören dass es ein neues
Pipeline lag geben soll in Polen wir
wissen noch nicht ganz genau was
dahinter steckt und an dem Tag an dem
eine Aussage vom Kanzler Olaf Scholz für
Irritationen sorgt der sagt nämlich nach
bald acht Monaten Krieg und unserer
tiefen Gaskrise er hat so vieles vorher
längst gewusst vorhergesehen schauen wir
noch mal
ich war mir immer sicher dass er das tun
würde der Kanzler als Besserwisser eine
Rede bei der deutschen Industrie und
Scholz behauptet er habe immer
vorausgesehen dass Putin sein Gas als
Waffe nutzen würde das gleiche gilt wenn
wir über die Frage diskutieren was ist
mit den Energielieferungen denn auch die
nutzt der russische Präsident als Waffe
ich war mir
immer sicher dass er das tun würde
und deshalb habe ich weil der Konflikt
ja schon da war wenn auch nicht so
eskaliert wie wir das dann seit dem
Februar gesehen haben mit dem Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine
habe ich mir schon im Dezember die Frage
gestellt und sie weitergegeben an alle
meine Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiter was
passiert eigentlich wenn Russland kein
Gast mehr liefert ein Kanzler der Wochen
vor dem Krieg Putins Gas Erpressung
vorhergesehen hat hier der Faktencheck
noch im dezember 2021 zwei Monate vor
dem Krieg sagte der Kanzler die Pipeline
habe mit der Lage in der Ukraine nicht
zu tun es handelt sich im Hinblick auf
Nord Stream 2 um ein
privatwirtschaftliches Vorhaben so
Scholz damals kurz danach besuchte er
Putin ich war mir
immer sicher dass er das tun würde immer
sicher dabei gehörte Scholz ja bereits
von 2007 bis 2009 als Arbeitsminister
der Bundesregierung an und war von 2018
bis 2021 Finanzminister in diesem Jahr
trug er den Pipeline Kurs Deutschlands
stets mit was ist mit den
Energielieferungen denn auch die nutzt
der russische Präsident als Waffe ich
war mir
immer sicher dass er das tun würde
herr Paul das sind schon eine Aussagen
die für Kopfschütteln sorgen also er
will es immer schon gewusst haben unser
Bundeskanzler das Putin eben das Gas als
Waffe einsetzt wann fragt sich
allerdings nur warum hat er dann nichts
getan
ja es gibt ja nur zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder er hat vorher gewusst und uns
bewusst verschwiegen und dann uns weiter
von Russland mit abhängig gemacht oder
er wusste ist damals nicht und tut heute
so als habe es gewusst ich weiß nicht
was schlimmer ist von beiden
Möglichkeiten ist besteht da in jedem
Fall dringender Aufklärungsbedarf denn
das klingt schon wahnsinnig absurd was
Olaf Scholz da sagt auch im Hinblick
darauf dass die SPD ja nicht einfach nur
mitgelaufen ist mit Kanzlerin Angela
Merkel die uns federführend als
Kanzlerin abhängig gemacht hat eben von
russischen Gaslieferung sondern ganz
vorne mit dabei war natürlich schon
unter Gerhard Schröder der dann zum
gaslobbyisten wurde aber auch mit
Manuela Schwesig zum Beispiel der
Ministerpräsidentin von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die eine
Umweltstiftung erfunden hat um Nord
Stream 2 in Betrieb zu bekommen die SPD
hat damals die Amerikaner ausgelacht
Heiko Maas bei den UN der über Donald
Trump den damaligen US-Präsidenten gel
das hat als er Deutschland gewarnt hatte
dass wir uns abhängig machen von
Russland
[Musik]